hi i'm rachel brosnahan i'm alex
forstein i'm tony chalu i'm mara and
hinkle i'm michael zeegan i'm kevin paul
i'm caroline aaron i'm luke kirby and we
are the cast of the marvelous mrs maisel
we're here to take a buzzfeed quiz to
figure out which character we are from
the show okay let's do it
what would your friend say is your
biggest star quality your sense of humor
creativity
stage presence fashion sense
hard working or positive attitude you're
an idiot if you don't know mine is
positive attitude
right and mine is fashion sense uh stage
presence creativity i'm hard-working but
not that hard working
i wouldn't put hard-working michael yeah
these are my closest friends i'll let
them decide i say fashion sense luke for
sharing
thanks choose something to order at the
stage deli pastrami on rye matzah ball
soup pickles potato knishes black and
white cookies or cheese danish
soup pastrami on rye nothing beats a
good pickle pickles i mean this is tough
it's it's
pastrami on rye and black and white
cookies i don't know i guess i'll go
pastrami on rye i gotta go with the soup
crew choose a funny tv lady to spend the
day with lorelei gilmore from gilmore
girls gloria delgado
from modern family rachel green from
friends leslie knope from parks and
recreation carrie bradshaw from sex in
the city issa d from insecure i gotta go
yeah i i i think so too i think just you
know for the blazers leslie knope
they're with you guys leslie isa ray is
dwight
i'm going rachel i'm going rachel green
i also work with with uh jennifer when
she was about i did a play with her when
she was about 17. i had a feeling she
was gonna blow up i like rachel green i
mean that she's actually that's the one
show that i've watched
watched it's the only one ever
yeah there's other good stuff on luke
i'll give you lists oh okay finally
choose somewhere to go on vacation paris
the catskills the upper west side
coney island las vegas or miami vegas
represents every part of the world in a
really sick dark way i know in a great
way so maybe maybe vegas is the answer
i'm treating this like like the price is
right so i'm going for the most
expensive trip to paris i gotta go with
paris i just think it's a no-brainer
yeah i'm going paris too yeah i'll see
you in paris
i got midge you did yeah i did it says
like midge you're a one-of-a-kind talent
but you're also willing to put in the
hard work to achieve your goals i'm a
hard worker but you know only so far i
got rose that which is not surprising
because i relate to her most i took the
test twice and the first time i was
susie meyerson and i was very unhappy
with that selection so i took it a
second time and i was marrying him which
i'm still a little disturbed by i got
susie meyerson well i got mid and i'm
thrilled because that means soon i'll be
able to wear the hats and the shoes i
got spooky i got midge
we were miscast clearly i want to trade
i want your suspenders and pants and i
will happily hand over all the unders
and the heels yeah i'm gonna pass on the
girdles and the heels and the big cap
and the wig and the hat and the lipstick
and the manicure i'm gonna pass actually
in real life we kind of are reversed at
least in the fashion department yeah i'm
a dainty flower
in a fashion
um i got shirley guys and i do want to
read it because it's so lovely like
shirley you have your quirks but that's
what makes you so lovable your adoration
of family so large sometimes it can feel
over the top but they are your number
one priority in life and they know it
that is really nice right and i'd love
for you to be me so i could fit in your
clothes
thank you buzzfeed i hope you uh
learned a lot here today we certainly
did and make sure you watch the
marvelous miss nasals season 4 on amazon
prime thank you buzzfeed here's a story
of a lovely lady
[Music]
you